zika fever
our newest dread disease
what is it where did it come from what
do we do about it
well for most adults it's a relatively
mild disease
little fever a little headache joint
pain
maybe a rash in fact most people who get
it don't even know they've had it
but the more we find out about the zika
virus
the more terrifying it becomes for
example doctors have noticed
an uptick of something called gillian
beret syndrome
in recent outbreaks in gilean beret your
immune system
attacks your nerve cells that can
partially or even totally paralyze you
fortunately that's quite rare and most
people recover
but if you're pregnant when you're
infected
you're at risk of something terrible
indeed
a child with a deformed head here's a
normal baby
here's an infant with what's called
microcephaly
a brain and a head that's too small
and there's no known cure sector it was
actually doctors
in northeastern brazil who first
noticed just a year ago after a
zika outbreak that there was a peak in
the
incidence of microcephaly it took
medical doctors another year to be sure
that it was caused by the zika virus
but they're now sure and if you're a
bring on the evidence
type check out this publication
so where did it come from and how did it
get here and it is here
like many of our viruses it came out of
africa
specifically the zika forest in uganda
researchers at the nearby yellow fever
research institute
identified an unknown virus in a monkey
in the
zika forest which is how it got its name
the first human cases of zika fever
surfaced a few years later in uganda
tanzania
the virus then spread through west
africa
and east through equatorial asia
pakistan india malaysia indonesia
but it was still mostly in monkeys and
of course mosquitoes
in fact in the 60 years between the time
was first identified in 1947
and 2007 there were only 13 reported
cases
of human zika fever and then something
extraordinary happened on the
tiny micronesian yap islands there was
an outbreak that affected fully 75
percent
of the population how did it get there
by air today we have two billion
commercial airline passengers
an infected passenger can board a plane
fly halfway around the world before
developing
symptoms if they develop symptoms at all
but then when they land the local
mosquitoes begin to bite them and spread
the fever
zika fever then next surfaced in 2013
in french polynesia by december of that
year
it was being transmitted locally by the
mosquitoes
that led to an explosive outbreak in
which almost 30
000 people were affected from there it
radiated
around the pacific there were outbreaks
in the cook islands
in new caledonia in vanuatu in the
solomon islands and
almost all the way around to the coast
of
south america and easter island and then
in early 2015 there was an
upsurge of cases of a dengue-like
syndrome
in the city of natal in northeastern
brazil
the virus wasn't dengue it was zika
and it spread rapidly rechife down the
coast
a big metropolitan center soon became
the epicenter
well people have speculated that it was
2014 world soccer cup fans that brought
the virus into the country
but others have speculated that perhaps
it was pacific islanders participating
in championship canoe races
that were held in rio that year that
brought it in
well today this is only a year later
the virus is being locally transmitted
by mosquitoes virtually throughout south
america central america mexico
and the caribbean islands until this
year
the many thousands of cases that have
been diagnosed in the u.s
were contracted elsewhere but
as of this summer it's being transmitted
locally
in miami it's here so what do we do
about it
well preventing infection
is either about protecting people or
about eliminating the mosquitoes
let's focus on people first you can get
vaccinated
you can not travel to zika areas
or you can cover up and apply insect
repellent
well getting vaccinated is not an option
because there isn't a vaccine yet and
they probably won't be for a couple of
years
staying home isn't a foolproof
protection either because we now know
that it can be sexually transmitted
covering up and applying insect
repellent does work
until you forget
so that leaves the mosquitoes and here's
how we control them now
spraying insecticides
the protective beer is necessary because
these are toxic chemicals that
kill people as well as bugs although it
does take quite a lot more to kill a
person
than to kill a bug these are pictures
from
brazil and nicaragua but it looks the
same
in miami florida and we of course
can spray insecticides from planes
back last summer mosquito control
officials
in dorchester county south carolina
authorized spraying
of naled an insecticide early one
morning as
recommended by the manufacturer well
later that day
a beekeeper told reporters that her bee
yard looked
like it had been nuked oops
these are the good guys well
the citizens of florida protested
but spraying continued unfortunately so
did the increase in the number of
zika fever cases and that's because
insecticides aren't very effective
so are there any approaches
that are perhaps more effective than
spraying
but less with less downsides than toxic
chemicals
well i'm a huge fan of biological
controls and i share that view
with rachel carson author of silent
spring the book that
is credited with starting the
environmental movement
in this book she tells the story as an
example
of how a very nasty insect
pest of livestock was eliminated in the
last century
no one knows that extraordinary story
today so
jack block and i when we were writing an
editorial
about the mosquito problem today retold
that story
and in capsule form it's that pupae
that's the immature form of the insect
were irradiated until they were sterile
grown to adulthood and then released
from planes all over the southwest
the southeast and down into mexico and
into central america
literally by the hundreds of millions
from little airplanes
eventually eliminating that terrible
insect pest from most of the western
hemisphere
well our real purpose in writing this
editorial was to introduce readers to
how we can do that today
not with radiation but with our
knowledge of genetics
let me explain this is the bad guy
aedes aegypti it's the most common
insect vector of
diseases not just zika but dengue
chikungunya west nile virus
and that ancient plague yellow fever
it's an urban mosquito and it's the
female
that does the dirty work she bites to
get a blood meal to feed her
offspring males don't bite they don't
even have the mouth parts
to buy a little company british company
called oxitec
genetically modified that mosquito so
that when it mates with a wild
female its eggs don't develop
to adulthood let me show you this is the
normal reproductive cycle oxitec
designed the mosquito so that when the
male mates with a wild female
the eggs don't develop sounds impossible
well let me show you just
diagrammatically how they do it
now this represents the nucleus of a
mosquito cell
and that tangle in the middle represents
its genome the sum total
of its genes the scientists added a
single gene
that codes for a protein represented by
this
orange ball that feeds back on itself
to keep cranking out more of that
protein
the extra copies however go and gum up
the mosquitoes genes killing the
organism
now to keep it alive in the laboratory
they use a compound called tetracycline
tetracycline shuts off that gene
and allows normal development now
they added another little wrinkle so
that they could study what happens
and that is they added a gene that'll
that
makes the insect glow under uv light
so that when they released it they could
follow exactly how far it went
how long it lived in all of the kinds of
data that you really need for a good
scientific study
now this is the pupil stage and at this
stage
the females are larger than the males
that allows them to sort them into the
males in the females
and they only they allow only the males
to grow to adulthood
and let me remind you that males don't
bite from there it's pretty simple
they take beakers full of male
mosquitoes
load them into milk cartons and drive
around the city releasing them
guided by gps here's the mayor of a city
releasing the first batch of what they
call the friendly
80s now i wish i could tell you this is
an american city but it's not
it's pure sicaba brazil the amazing
thing
is that in just a year it brought down
the cases of dengue by 91
that's better than any insecticide
spraying can do
so why aren't we using this remarkable
biological control
in the u.s and that's because
it's a gmo a genetically modified
organism notice the subtitle here says
if the
fda would let them they could do the
same thing
here when zika arrives then of course it
has arrived
so now i have to tell you the short form
of the long
tortuous story of gm regulation
in the u.s in the u.s
there are three agencies that regulate
genetically modified organisms
the fda the food and drug administration
the epa the environmental protection
agency and the usda
us department of agriculture took these
folks
two years to decide that it would be the
fda
that would regulate the genetically
modified mosquito and they would do it
as a new animal drug if that makes any
sense
took them another five years going back
and forth and back and forth
to convince the fda
that this would not harm people and it
would not harm the environment
they finally gave them this summer
permission to run a little
test in the florida keys where they had
been
invited years earlier when the keys had
had
an outbreak of dengue
would that it were that easy when the
local residents
heard that there would be genetically
modified mosquitoes tested in their
community
some of them began to organize protests
they even organized
a petition on the internet with this
cuddly logo
which eventually accumulated some 160
000 signatures and they demanded a
referendum which will be
conducted in just a couple of weeks
about whether the trials would be
permitted at all
well it's miami that really needs these
better ways
of controlling insects and there the
attitudes are
changing in fact very recently a
bipartisan group
of more than 60 legislators wrote to hha
secretary sylvia burwell asking that she
at the federal level
expedite access for florida to this new
technology
so the bottom line is this biological
control
of harmful insects can be
both more effective and very much more
environmentally friendly
than using insecticides which are toxic
chemicals that was true in rachel
carson's time
it's true today what's different is that
we have
enormously more information
about genetics than we have then and
therefore more ability
to use that information to affect these
biological controls
and i hope that what i've done is
aroused your curiosity enough to start
your own
inquiry not into just gm mosquitoes
but to the other genetically modified
organisms that are so controversial
today
i think if you do that and you dig down
through all of the misinformation and
the marketing
on the part of the organic food industry
and the green pieces
and find the science the accurate
science
you'll be surprised and pleased thank
[Applause]
you